[Music]
hello my name is Caleb Ben boo and
welcome back to the road mm I've always
I'm your driver on this journey it's day
on the road I wanted to take a break
from the serious chest study at the time
of recording this or actually in the
middle of course of the coronavirus
extravaganza
so everybody's hunkered down everybody's
looking for things to do I'm sure bored
out of their minds and so today instead
of going over some more serious chess
instruction I wanted to remind everyone
that chess is a very fun board game and
can be played in many different ways
that's right today we're going over some
chess variants if you take a look at the
position I have on the board here you'll
see that a few things are different than
normal chess for one white seems to have
a lot of puns nobody knows how many I
cannot even count that high that being
said it's definitely 36 and black seems
to have a full set of chess pieces also
notably white does not have a king and
therefore he cannot be checkmated pretty
powerful stuff and this variant actually
goes by the name of hoard chess I'm
going over it on a li chess study here
and I I will mention that Li chess is a
great place to play hoard if you're
interested in trying out what you're
about to learn in this lecture now
before I jump into this game that I
actually played in in horn chess I
wanted to go over first of all the rules
and then some basic strategy and we'll
see how that turns out in a real game so
of course the rules to horde are going
to be a little bit different because
white doesn't have a king so I have here
a very basic chess position
well hoard position where white is down
to the last two pawns and black is down
to just the king in this position white
wins if he checkmates the black King and
black wins if he simply takes all of
White's pawns so what that looks like is
something like this and black would win
the game white has to move so white
plays d7 black takes white
has to move again white plays the only
move and black takes and so black would
would win this game also notably in a
horde the stalemate rule is still in
effect and that can be a little bit you
know tricky so for example if in this
position we had King takes T seven and
now E six and black for some reason
played King g7 black would not win this
is still a draw additionally of course
what what does checkmate look like well
it looks like something like this this
rule is the same as in chess you simply
have to checkmate
the black King in order to win with the
white pieces and so white usually
accomplishes this by a cleaning of pawn
and the characteristic of the game kind
of turns out to be can black get behind
the pawns to take them all out or can
white promote just one of the pawns
if white promotes a single pawn then
almost always white is simply winning
the game that being said let's go back
to this terrifying looking position here
in the opening and so it's well and easy
to understand the rules of Port you know
black takes all of the white pawns and
then black wins or white promotes to a
queen and then checkmates black and
white wins but what does this actually
look like in a game well there's a few
things that you can already just kind of
keep in mind and implement into your own
games if you find yourself playing the
side with the puns note that you're
actually add a little bit of a
disadvantage it's generally understood
that the pieces do have the upper hand
in the game of horde chess as it
currently stands but there are a few
things you can try to do for example d5
is a very common first move one of the
let's see five six seven eight
of course these moves all hang upon so
one of the four main moves and let's say
just for example black responds with the
move
six it's not a bad move but after D four
you can imagine black plays a move like
d6 and this is the first kind of rule I
want you guys to try to implement width
of the pawns you should try and keep
things closed and actually avoid trading
your pawns for the pawns of your
opponent
that's because if the positions closed
it doesn't really matter to your pawns
they can only move one space at a time
anyways and they're going to come up the
board by force whereas the pieces if the
position is very closed they're going to
be blocked in by their own pawns
so for example after c6 it's going to be
difficult to develop this Knight it's
going to be difficult to get this rook
out it's going to be difficult for the
Queen to influence the Queen side at all
and it's going to be kind of a tough
game for black already for example the
game might continue something like e six
black is probably gonna try to break out
on the King side of the board since the
Queen side got so locked down and just
to play some moves something like d3 a6
D two and a five note that I actually
took this game from a real game that was
played between two high-level horde
players I will probably admit that a-six
a-five was a bit of a mouse slip but
we're just gonna keep rolling here let's
say H 597 take only six take on a six
now it would actually be a mistake for
white to take on e6 because it's
generally favourable to trade off a
piece for two pawns when they're so far
advanced into the position so that's
another rule to keep in mind a piece for
two pawns
if the pawns are very far advanced is
gonna be favorable for the pieces also
something to keep in mind if you ever
get three pawns for a piece with the
pieces you're killing it three pawns
four piece is absolutely always a
fantastic trade for the side with the
pieces
so of course not takes on these six
instead h4 and I'll play through some
moves quickly here the point I'm trying
to get across with this example is
you'll notice white simply plays over
here on the Kings side just pushing
these pawns forward and these black
pieces are all kind of locked out of the
game by blacks opening choice and will
actually see a bit later on
black really struggles to get into the
game and these white pawns just roll up
the board effortlessly and eventually
black cracks and actually sacrifices to
pieces for two measly pawns which is of
course going to be a good trade for the
white player and from here white went on
to win the game using all of these open
pawns on open files now let's look at a
different opening we just looked at d6
which is a fine first move but with b6
it is a little bit suspect to allow
white to take all this space so let's
instead look at a move like c6 which
increases the pawn tension to the
maximum after a six let's say white
plays d4 perfectly reasonable move what
I'm gonna recommend for the black player
rather than allowing white to keep
things closed you immediately want to
take things in the middle of the board
open things up as well as open up your
rooks
on the rook files the starting files and
so let's take a look at similar moves
here let's say e for something like d6
is already going to be good for black
you're trying to just open up more
diagonals more lines for your pieces if
white tries c6 now well you're gonna get
hit with a move like 97 you're not
relieving the tension with a move like
b6 you're increasing it and threatening
to trade off your one piece for two
powerful advanced pawns which as I said
is generally a favorable trade for the
pieces and just for example here if I
move like d3 well you can take on c6
and let's say takes one before and you
can take on c6 and already this is going
to be a difficult game for the white
player and in fact this is a game I took
also from the lead chess database and
white did end up losing this one to
black so those are some basic principles
that I wanted to start with one you want
to keep things closed if you're the
pawns generally and two you want to open
up as many lines for your pieces as
possible as black this is kind of a
standard way of playing I also wanted to
mention before we get too into things
that there is a pretty interesting
dynamic with the rooks on their starting
files in the game afford chess and just
to kind of point that out I'm gonna put
some moves on the board here let's say
d5 and to move like h5 okay and let's
say it white captures this pawn on h5
and black captures back the rook on the
H&A files are actually extremely
powerful pieces in hoard chess and the
reason for that is well let's imagine
white does nothing and black does
nothing here even keeping the rook back
on h8 obviously white can never push the
move h5 without defending that square
first white can just take it okay
but the problem is white can never
defend the h5 square unless he plays the
move g4 the obvious drawback to g4 well
you're giving up this H pawn on h4 and
so like this the rook on the rook files
are actually controlling two files all
by themselves so you can imagine it'd be
disastrous for white if something like
this were to happen now all of these
ponds are completely frozen and you're
going to have to try to win against the
rest of blacks are me with these center
four files and that's simply not going
to have it
so things to keep in mind so far trading
one piece for to advanced pawns
generally good for the side with the
pieces trading one piece for three pawns
always good for the side with the pieces
and if you can get your rooks on open
files on the a and H files they're going
to be powerful pieces now understandably
it's still probably a little bit
difficult to kind of conceptualize how a
full game looks so I want to jump into
that after introducing the last and
final idea if you have the black pieces
obviously the best way to attack pawns
is from behind so the general goal for
black is to get a queen behind these
pawns and then you can really just start
cleaning them up one by one attacking
the pawn from the base of in this case
less of a pawn chain more of a pawn
horde as the name would imply and so
these are the basic principles of horde
that I wanted to introduce to you now I
neglected to open the chat before I
started this show so I'm gonna do that
now and ask you guys if you have any
questions on these basic principles any
questions for me on the basic principles
so far oh yes good question how does
this help us get to mm well as I stated
this is not so much about serious chess
study it's about enjoying the game of
chess enjoying the game of chess in
various forms a the biggest reason why
people don't improve a chess is they get
bored and stop playing it and so
variants can be a fun little side thing
that you can do to keep yourself
interested in the board game when maybe
you're becoming a little bit unhappy
with the actual game of chess and your
improvement there
and even if you are happy with the
actual game of chess variants can be
just a fun fun exercise as well okay
with that in mind we're going to move on
to the first game of the day which was
played between myself and Ally chest
user by the name of cinder wasps now in
this game white did play d5 I played
this movie six like I mentioned at the
beginning just increasing the pond
tension white played the move d4 and now
rather than take red away I simply
played d6 first so we are fighting for
the center of the board just like in
real chess now white plays the move
a5 which prevents me from playing this
move
a5 myself like I said usually a good
idea to try to get the rooks on to open
files in response I played the move h5
trying to open up my rook on the other
side of the board my opponent played the
move G takes aged six which is a
perfectly fine move I played Knight
takes h6 now we saw my opponent actually
have to make a decision already and this
is how a court kind of develops and in
its opening stages you have these
principles you know trading a piece for
to advanced pawns is generally favorable
for the pieces and they kind of dictate
what decisions the white player has to
make so in this case I'm actually
threatening to open up these lines with
D takes c6 for example let's say white
place and move like d3 I'm threatening
to play ticks takes and oh well maybe I
would take with the bishop and Knight
takes
and now not only have I traded one piece
for two ponds which is okay for blacks
sometimes good depending on how far
advanced there
I'm also threatening to take off another
pawn on h4 and this is very relevant
because these rook files are really
where the pawns are weak at preventing
other black pieces from entering and
that's simply because there's no pea
pond to the left of these ponds to help
support so they have to get all of their
support from these GE ponds and so if
black can sacrifice some pieces along
this h-file
he'll be able to infiltrate with the
major pieces and especially the Queen
and like I said that's kind of the
winning plan for black so that is all to
say I'm making a threat to take on f5
and start coming out white with some of
these ideas white understandably took on
e6 to avoid this but now after F takes G
six we're kind of achieving another good
thing for the pieces we're trading pawns
to open lines for our pieces and giving
us more opportunities to try and break
through now I'm probably going to play
stuff like this my opponent chose to
play D takes a six which is I think
totally fine but it did strike me as a
little bit odd maybe it was better to
just leave this pawn on d5 but that's
fine I simply take back with the bishop
and now once again fearing these pieces
working together on the g4 pawn he
played g5 and now I want to ask the chat
to try to come up with a good move here
for black can you come up with a good
hoard chess move
a good horn chess move
while you're thinking about that I'll
answer some of these questions why
thirty-six ponds and how was it invented
as a variant I'm not a hundred percent
up-to-date on who invented the variant
it's kind of just a natural funny idea
that I'm sure just saw play well
somebody tried it and they came up with
this as 436 pawns there are a couple
variations of it some with more pawns
some with fewer pawns and I think 36
just ended up being a good number to
make the game fairly balanced and that's
that's what they stuck with how better
is black well practically I think if you
get good at the game black is usually
supposed to supposed to be winning if
you check the statistics I think black
does very very well but at most levels
including like everybody but like the
best horde players in the world probably
white also has pretty decent chances
alright we've got a few suggestion
suggestions Queen d7 and Knight f1 have
both been suggested as has Queen D 1
which is less legal and I like one of
those moves a lot more than the other
one neither of them are what I played in
the game but Queen d7 shares the same
idea as what I had with Queen c8 and the
point here is that if you play a move
like Knight f7
this move is perfectly fine but you're
going to give white an opportunity to
kind of start trying to roll over some
of your pieces here in the meantime
with Queen to c8 we're already eyeing
this pawn on h3 and not giving black
time to play a move like g4 to block us
out for example a similar way this could
progress is something like this and
let's say it why it passes for a turn
and you play Queen c8 well now you might
get hit well I guess not with g4 pinging
this pawn
but you are wasting a bit more time and
the move f5 could be played and while
this sacrifice does get to pawns for the
piece it is not really opening up more
lines for your major pieces to get into
the game so all of that is to say I like
this move Queen c8 or Queen d7 a bit
better with the idea of Bishop takes h3
from there my opponent accepted my
sacrifice of the night with G takes h6 I
simply recaptured and now worried about
Bishop takes h3 he did continue through
with f5 now I could take on at five
getting two pawns for the piece but I
liked the pressure that this Bishop
exerted on h3 so I simply retreated and
now after d3 g6 is my idea and now this
is kind of a how how [ __ ] just games go
a lot the idea isn't so much to battle
white on all fronts on the board but you
want to try to organize your pieces to
chip away at one side of the board -
then get of course your major pieces in
so you can start cleaning up the pawns
from behind so g6 was my move just
trying to open up this diagonal and
already I think white is in a very tough
spot I consult the lead chess engine it
says it's about equal actually but I
think practically this is good for good
for black my opponent wasn't quite sure
what to do simply play d2 which of
course allows me to take on f5 take on
f5 Bishop takes f5 and now this is going
to come crashing through
now of course black I think is in fact
winning Eve or was played this allows of
course Bishop takes h3 and be a mistake
now for white to capture this piece
because after Queen takes you cannot
stop me from coming into your position
and taking away all of your pawns
instead III was played but the damage
has already been done now Bishop e7
comes through and the idea is the same
we're simply going to take off more of
these pawns and invade with the pieces
and this is exactly how the game
progresses C takes D six was played and
take back with the pawn now after c5 I
simply take on c5 take on c5 and I could
take on h4 here but instead I simply
take off the C pawn because at the end
of the day I'm gonna take on c5 and
these pawns are going to fall now Bishop
takes h2 might have been a little bit
silly I could have just taken here
instead and then cleaned up more puns
but it's still okay for black a4 a6
threatens to open up the rook c4 was
played and this simply allows a takes b5
and now the rook comes into a five as
well and from here I did manage to win
but of course this was a blitz game
people don't really play standard toward
chess too often and so I managed to hang
my rook but at the end of everything the
Queen managed to invade and this game
ended pretty quickly afterwards the
Queen just cleans up all the pawns once
you get behind the pawns the interesting
part of the game is mostly over and from
here black cleaned up in one the game so
this is what a full game of horde chess
actually looks like it's kind of this
balance where white is trying to come up
the board and black is trying to find
ways to chip at the pawn wall to get a
major piece behind the pawns in order to
actually capture them all and so this is
what it looks like when black does well
you have a few key moments here in this
opening black tried to take off as many
pawns as possible trading pawns opening
files for the pieces and then from here
I simply started to attack
the age file in order to get a major
piece through and that's what happened
white got impatient on the queenside
because there was so much pressure on
the Kings side and then this allowed me
to invade with my pieces any questions
on this horde game so far any questions
it's a lot to kind of take in
it's a lot to take in okay no questions
no questions we'll continue on
we'll continue on and now this is a game
I played with the same user when we
played two games in a row so that each
of us could could have the white pieces
once and this game I had the pawns of
course and I played d5 my opponent
played a six I continued through with h5
now the idea being of course to prevent
h5 from my opponent d6 was played I
played d4 simply pushing forward and
you'll notice with the pawns you
sometimes have a lot fewer decisions to
make
you kind of just come up the board and
it's really black who has the the
responsibility of coming up with
interesting strategies to take out the
pawns was searching forward there hope I
found it
my opponent now tried a 5 to open up
this a rook
I took it slow played d3 97 came from my
opponent and now I captured on d6 I
captured him he's captured on d6 and we
took everything because I kind of
realized that eventually this was going
to have to happen and it might as well
happen now Bishop takes c6 comes on the
board and now I played d5 hitting the
bishop the bishop comes back to f7 and I
just slowly advanced the pawns up the
board b6 was my opponent's choice and
this move struck me as a bit odd it
doesn't really make sense to play b6
here you like actually having this Queen
to come out to the a file if necessary
and an interesting maneuver for black is
actually 97 when if let's say I do
nothing you might consider coming out to
b6 with the idea of capturing on h4 and
capturing on a
this is a nice maneuver for black to
once again start chipping away at one of
these rook files to get the pieces into
the game so b6 was a bit of a bad move I
believe I continued through with d3 this
might be a rule I forgot to mention as
well as the pawns on the second rank
being able to move two squares on the
first turn the pawns on the first rank
share the same rule as well so d3 a
legal move here believe it or not and
now my opponent I think kind of just ran
out of things to do
played the move Knight g8 trying to
clear this Square for the bishop but it
does seem a bit weird
h4 simply supports this pawn further 97
and now I play f5 and so something I
wanted to mention which I've done with
my D pawns especially is when you do
have the pawns I think it's a bit better
to bring the pawns from the first and
second rows up a bit before you start to
open things up now obviously this
changes if your opponent is playing
really well and threatening to invade on
one side of the board then you kind of
have to hasten things up a bit but in
general you want to move the pawns
together you don't want to throw pawns
forward without any support Queeny 7 was
black's choice now simply f4 and now my
opponent does something interesting and
this is a strategy that is used a lot in
horde chess the strategy is white does
not have the ability to pass and so what
this means is if black can set up a type
of position where on the front lines no
matter what white plays it's going to be
losing material losing pawns then
sometimes it's good for black to simply
pass the move back to white until he is
forced to do so
and so here I have moved the pawns from
the back row up as far as they can and
now I do have to make a decision here I
have to push one of the pawns
now this isn't always a bad idea from
black in fact it's a very strong idea
that is often used to just win the game
but in this case the bad news for black
is that I actually have a couple really
good options here now a move like c5
would of course be horrible black can
just take this pawn and come crashing
through with the pieces activating
everything instead I have the move g6
and this move actually doesn't even lose
any pawns in fact it traps black's
bishop
okay and so yeah after g6 the Bishop on
f7 is totally trapped h6 g6 F takes G
six was my choice and this bishop has
nowhere to go
Knight GF 6 I take on f7 Queen takes f7
and I will mention a piece for to
advanced pawns is usually good for the
pieces a piece for one pawn it's it's
gonna be good for the pawns
just like in real chess now from here
white still has some problems with being
able to pass but I do break through with
the move e5 now D takes e5 is played I
take back with the D pawn and now my
opponent is kind of losing the threat of
things and just start sacrificing on the
H file I could take back in this is fine
for blood fine for white but the movie
six actually wins more material here so
I get another piece for one pawn and
another piece for two pawns in this case
and now White has or black has simply
sacrificed too much material for too
little and the pawns are able to roll
through here in the game
efore d5 was played I continue through a
d4 and e4 just moving the pawns as a
mass and from here in the game ended
relatively without controversy if I
remember correctly although no it
definitely did not because I played some
very bad moves of course in this
position white is totally totally
winning you simply have to play the move
III and then push these pawns up the
board and there's not much that black
can do about it can even play a move
like d6 c4 d 6 C 5 and this game is
gonna be over in the game though and
this will happen in your horde games
quite a lot I forgot to defend my pawns
and I played the move c4 just assuming
this eponymous defended somehow it of
course is not so Queen takes d4 comes on
the board and all of a sudden it's it's
it's a game again
in the game c3 was played Queen d1 and
now I play the move a3 simply preparing
the move
b4 of course forgetting that the b-pawn
is attacked and so if Queen takes b3
were played finally black is going to be
winning the game unfortunately for him
he missed this and took on c1 and now
after B for white is once again going to
be winning this game while the black
queen is in time to be behind the pawns
and start cleaning things up
unfortunately for black these ponds are
rolling just a bit too quickly Queen
takes c3 b6 was my choice and now I
spoke too soon black actually has one
move to save the game so test your horde
prowess here see if you can find blacks
one move or one move to save the game
here there's only one idea that does it
it's an idea that both me and my
opponent missed see if you can find it
here
what can be done for black to try to
stop these ponds black has done a great
job of invading with the Queen and
starting to clean up hugs from the Hinds
but the threat of c7 and takes on takes
on b8 it's going to be very difficult to
stop does anybody think they have it
nobody knows nobody knows what can be
done of course the correct answer nobody
found it this is unusual for us here
usually somebody is on the ball the move
is rook h7 and you can simply defend
along the seventh rank sacrificing your
rook for two of the pawns and then the
rest of the pieces are not or the rest
of the pawns are not in time to continue
pushing so Rick h7 would be the winning
move here fortunately for my opponent he
missed it and I checked and queens and
the game quickly ended with checkmate so
these are some examples of how horde
chess is played at I would say you know
a reasonable level you know my opponent
kind of knew what he was doing
he's been playing hoard he's 1850 Onley
chess which is actually pretty high
rated the hoard ratings are a bit
deflated and 1850s is a pretty
knowledgeable player actually
oh my gosh now everybody has ideas and
they did in fact find it alright moving
on I wanted to show my highest-rated
horde win ever it was against a very
strong horde player by the name of
Steuben fish I think
Steuben fish is still on leach s he is
in and out of the top 10 of horde I
think he's been number one he's been
number two he's been number three he's
he's up there and this is a game I
played against him where I had the white
pieces and miraculously managed to win
the game though not really on position
if my memory serves me correctly so
let's see how stupid fish handles the
black pieces a you know I would say
world class horde player d5 was my
choice NYX I simply played d4 my
opponent captured on d5 immediately I
captured back and he went for a five you
know using these same basic principles
opening up lines opening up the rooks on
the rook files you for d6 I play the
move III just kind of biding my time
pushing the pawns forward now Knight d7
from my opponent already makes a threat
so you'll see how quickly stupid fish is
threatening to open up lines and
sacrifices pieces to take away at my
powerful pawns for example if I do
nothing here play a move like d3 the
move D takes c5 is likely already going
to come on the board and after B takes
d5 and you can sacrifice the night if
you like and take back with the bishop
and now you'll see already holes are
beginning to form in
the in the white camp here if I'm not
careful move like Queenie seven might
come and Bishop takes a three is already
going to be a bit of a threat so in the
game rather than play d3 c6 I think is
widely regarded as the best move but
already black is is doing quite well
instead I chose to move b6 just creating
some more attention here of course this
allows black to capture on c5 anyways I
took back on c5 perhaps I should have
taken on c7 just preserving more puns
but after C takes b6 now I play the move
c6
trying at all costs to uh to create
complications here so after c6 B takes
c6 was played D takes c6 now Knight B
eight threatens the pawn d5 and
ninety-seven so you see stupid fish
using this principle of sacrificing one
piece for to advanced pawns to great
effect here he's drawn my pawn forward
with these threats of sacrifices and now
that the pawn is so far advanced he's
able to get this exchange on the board I
play the move d4 now and he immediately
sacrifices getting the rest of his
pieces in the game I continue up with d3
now f6 from Stephen fish is already once
again creating threats on the side of
the board I take on f6 and he takes back
on f6 opening up more lines for the
black pieces and this position is
honestly pretty grim for white already
well the rook files are closed it's not
going to be easy for me to push forward
because the threat of him taking and
taking is always going to be there so
these files are more or less locked down
for me now next up these files can still
move around just a bit but it's going to
be tough to play on just this one side
of the board when black has only
sacrificed one piece so far to take out
a lot of mine
central pawns in the game I tried a five
and my opponent responded with Bishop g7
a perfectly fine move I took on f6
Bishop takes f6 and now after d5 97
these pawns are beginning to look a
little bit weak I mentioned before the
pawns are weakest on the sides of the
board where they're only defended by one
file of puns but when you get down to
this few ponds it's really difficult to
keep the files closed and keep the Queen
out and that's what we'll see happen
here I played Eve for trying to create
this trying to give this pawn more
support make it a strong point Bishop b7
was played now continue with g5 kind of
pushing forward at all costs Bishop back
to g7 was played now f6 and my opponent
sacrifices here sacrifices here
sacrifices here and takes back here and
what has black achieved with all of
these sacrifices well now he has no more
pieces but the fact is I only have these
two pawns remaining these two pawns are
all that stand between the black queen
and taking the rest of my entire army
and so stupid fish is going to be able
to use that to his advantage to break
through and to in fact win this game I
played III and now king f7 comes on the
board and this pawn is indefensible
I tried g4 he simply takes off this pawn
now h5 was my move
and the rest is kind of history here I
try to bring the pawns forward but now
the rooks come to bear down on these two
weak central pawns g5 check was my move
King g7 and I pushed through with f5 but
it's too little too late
take stakes
queen bee five was his move actually
missing a winning tactic here so see if
you at home can find the winning tactic
I'll give you just a moment because
there is a bit of a delay I've been told
to see if you can find the winning
tactic winning idea here for for black
ah we have a top 10 horn player in the
chat in the in the form of cinema 73 we
are not playing hard chess today we're
just learning about it introducing the
game introducing the game
I did not play in the crazy house or in
the Horde World Championship although
that question may not be for me cinnamon
the top 10 horde player in the world
does find the tactic its rook takes III
F takes III and then you get hit with
this move Queen c5 which bears down on
this F pawn and also this pawn on on e3
if you play a move like f2 I'll simply
Queen f5 and you can't keep this Queen
out of everywhere play G - I'll take
here and now the fact of the matter is
you're just out of pawns you can't let
the Queen in here so you have to go up
the H pawn as well and this is just
going to be hopeless not enough pawns
left and these pawns on the left side of
the board you'll see are still totally
locked down by the black pawns so ro
takes c3 would have been nice of course
this was a very fast game Queen e5 was
played instead now after E for rook f8
was black choice trying to sacrifice
here to get in here I chose f4 to kick
the Queen back queenie 8 and now I chose
g4 to defend these pawns rook f7 was my
opponent's choice perhaps a bit better
was Rick takes f5 the idea being I can't
keep the Queen out of both squares so
Rick f7 and now h4 once again Rick takes
f5 is an idea instead the rookie 7 was
my opponent's choice I defend this pawn
at all costs and now my opponent plays
rook d7 and he's kind of failing to
invade with the pieces for the moment I
chose the move in d4 perhaps better was
already just pushing these pawns forward
with a move like f6 and then from there
to play move like a 5 and these pawns
aren't actually quite dangerous this far
up the board ignore these arrows
dangerous this far up the board however
though I tried pushing with d4 and this
is already kind of missing the point now
Queen d8 is in fact going to be breaking
through and so I just didn't play
quickly enough now I did try f6 King g8
and I continued through with the move e5
trying to get these pawns to the end of
the board
but now rook takes d4 is invading with
the black pieces I try g3 holding on to
the base of my pawn chain but Queen f2
comes on the board and I think white is
simply losing here
I played h6 he played Queen takes g3 and
now I played h5 but the pawns are
collapsing g6 Queen takes h6 and after a
6 there's not much left to do East 7 and
white is dead lost here
but once again somehow it has gotten a
bit tricky if I were my opponent I might
have played the move Queen g5 instead
collecting the farthest advance pawn
before it becomes too much of an issue
of course f7 check is allowed but now
this e pawn is going to fall and once
again these pawns on this side of the
board totally worthless to me instead
the Queen III c 7 this force is black to
find the only move here to maintain the
the winning advantage and in fact he did
not manage to find it in this game which
is why y ended up winning
so the big follow up does anybody see or
the big the big move to to win the game
all right I'm assuming you guys have
already found it at home it is King h8
of course you need to step out of f7
check now if f7 of course you can
capture this pawn and so the move now
for white is a little bit difficult to
find there's really nothing to do can
try f4 Black is simply going to
sacrifice this rook on the next turn and
there's nothing to be done just going to
take this and now the Queen can easily
stop the King side pawns and for the
billionth time these pawns are worthless
to me instead though my opponent missed
the killer move King h8 stopping f7
check with the idea of f8 and now after
f7 my opponent has nothing better than
to give up the full queen fort here and
so he does King takes f7 now finally I
try to make the pawns on the set of the
board worth something now that the queen
is off the board my opponent collects my
e7 pawn but I am starting to break
through on the Queen side the game
continued a little bit I'll play some
more moves and white should just be
winning here to the sheer number of
pawns rook takes g4 a5 and these pawns
do roll up the board in tandem with each
other and after b3 intakes or okay -
rook c2 rather after a 6 this rook now
does have to come back to the eighth
rank in order to prevent the pawns from
advancing so it comes back to d2 and
after a 5 all the way back to d8
now this is my next question for you
guys can you find the winning plan here
for whites
how does white ever win this game how do
you win what pawns do you need to
advance
for the rest of the game I will say
black is going to be shuffling back and
forth on this 8th rank so you don't have
to worry about black taking your pawns
until you start pushing them
how does white ever win this game it's
it's a really difficult question
actually it's not as simple as you might
think with all these puns notably
these ponds are worthless this rook just
being on the eighth-ranked is always
going to stop them
if you can't force this rook off the
eighth-ranked and these pawns are not
going to be doing anything
not going to be doing anything
got to be the a pawns so how can you get
the a pawns down the board how can you
get the a pawns down the board it's not
so clear it's not so easy Peter wants to
play a seven so black is gonna pass and
in fact I will say Peter made the same
mistake I did by playing a seven a seven
and this is a losing move white is
completely lost after the move a seven
and that is not what you would expect
with all of these pawns on the board
however there's simply no way to advance
the pawns after a seven in fact the
winning idea is to leave this pawn on a
six so for example if we push all these
pawns first which we can do just for fun
like I said black is gonna be passing
for the rest of the game why not even
bring this H pawn up here as well don't
hang your rook h4 and even h5 even even
h6 and now even b4 just push all the
pawns why not now the idea is instead of
pushing a seven you're gonna push b6 and
a key point is that this pawn still
defends the b7 square now after King
takes c6 you're not going to push a
seven you're going to play b5 check and
this King is going to be driven further
away from the ponds which now allows you
to play a seven and a six in tandem so
you keep control of the b7 Square and
now obviously white is going to push and
win now in the game I played a seven
here now what's the downside well we're
about to see I push all the pawns as we
saw in the game these pawns just come up
the board and now you run into this
position and you say ha aya can't Queen
you play b6 white our black is simply
going to take on c6
and now there's no way to advance these
pawns if you played b5 simply King b7
and black is totally totally winning
you cannot play a7 in the game though my
opponent took on c6
I played a6 and he lost on time so
that's how I beat one of the top 10
horde players at the time I don't know
if he still is or not but a world-class
word player of course as always with my
chess games the answer is I played badly
and won on time that's that's the way
you got to do it sometimes so I think
that's the last hoard game I'm gonna go
over for the day thank you very much for
joining me for horde now we're going to
switch gears completely to another one
of my favorite variants that is going to
be atomic chess
okay atomic chess of course is the type
of chess where when pieces are captured
they explode we have explosive pieces so
I just wanted to introduce the rules
here first when a piece is captured all
of the pieces in the surrounding square
these eight squares surrounding the
captured piece are all taken off the
board thankfully a quote-unquote explode
and the exception to this rule is
actually going to be pawns pawns only
get taken off the board if they capture
something or if they are captured
themselves so for example if Queen takes
a six is played here the surrounding
pieces are taken off the board including
the Queen itself except for this pot
because it was not directly captured and
of course puns when they directly
capture something or are directly
captured are taken off the board so if
pawn takes pawn is played both pawns are
taken off the board these are the basic
rules of atomic now there's a few more
rules to get familiar with before you're
ready to play an atomic game and those
rules have to do with the King so if it
were white to move here white would take
on d8 exploding the black King and
winning the game but you might say to
yourself well it's black to move is
Queen ASIC
checkmate and the answer is no it is not
it's true that the king is in check all
of these squares are defended you cannot
take the C pawn because Kings can't
capture pieces and atomic otherwise they
would explode and okay if something like
King d5 obviously black is going to come
through with Queen b6 so Queen a6 looks
like a pretty good move looks pretty
good
however this move actually losses on the
spot check is not the objective in
atomic chess
neither is checkmate the objective is to
explode the enemy King so Queen a6 is
attacking the King but white is actually
legally allowed to take on d8 winning
the game by exploding the black King so
note that check is not as forcing as it
is in chess because in this case white
is already threatening the black King so
you could look at it as black being in
check in the initial position you could
look at it that way so Queen a6
obviously a bad move well now you might
be thinking is white just winning the
game if you move this bishop out of the
way for example Queen d8 now actually
looks like it ends the game the black
king is attacked and all of these
squares are defended but this brings up
the weirdest rule of atomic chess and
that rule is that Kings are allowed to
touch now this is a huge no-no in real
chess but in atomic chess these things
are allowed to happen the pawn on c5 is
breaking the rules of atomic just yet
doubled pawns are not legally allowed to
happen but we'll just ignore that for
now just think of it as a position so
the kings are allowed to touch in atomic
chess and the reason is they can't
legally capture anything so the kings
are kind of pacifists in atomic chess
and so because they aren't allowed to
capture anything they're led to touch
like this also notably it's legal for
white to capture the black King here
because why it would be taking his own
King off the
as well and this creates some
interesting endgame problems where it's
usually best for the defending side to
chase the King around as much as
possible those are the rules of atomic
chess pieces in the surrounding square
all explode when a piece is captured and
Kings are allowed to touch check is not
forcing because the threat of exploding
a king is enough to end the game now
with the last 10 minutes I wanted to
introduce some opening theory which is
actually pivotal in atomic chess due to
the power of all of the pieces in this
variants white actually has a pretty
great starting advantage from the
initial position in a big reason for
that excellent a big reason for that is
this move Knight f3 Knight f3 creates a
lot of threats for example if you play a
normal move like Knight f6 well this is
simply going to be game ending you
cannot prevent white from capturing one
of these pawns and blowing up the black
King if you play a normal move like d5
well already you're going to be
checkmated quite quickly threatening to
blow up the King Queen d7 or something
and now something like
sorry you're not gonna play night of
seven I'm gonna play Knight d7 forcing
this Bishop to explode and end the game
so you have to be very very careful with
black and atomic chess and in fact the
only real first move for black to try to
keep the game going is going to be F 6 e
5 is a playable move to stop you 95 of
course because it would explode but now
Knight g5 is winning quite a lot of
material using these threats so f6 is
really the main move for black it's the
only thing that you'll see being played
if both players are pretty good at the
game and really are trying their hardest
to get a good position now a common
follow-up is the moved III what's the
reason for that well the Queen quite
often is able to create checkmating
ideas from the start of the game for
example let's say a black plays a move
like 96 now 95 is already actually
checkmate once again the reason being
you have to take this night off
otherwise 97 will come so you take the
night but now Queen h5 g6 is the only
move and Queen d5 is already forking two
key squares here and the black king will
die once again so the two main moves
found after e3 are really going to be d5
in e6 these are the ways to prevent this
Knight move from ending the game and
today I would like take a look at this
movie 6 and talk a little bit about how
a high-level game might transpire after
the movie 6 so let's look at Knight d4
which is the main move for white now
white is not threatening checkmate but
is threatening to win massive amounts of
material on the c7 square so c6 is the
common reply now Knight b5 comes on the
board anyways with the idea being you're
still going to play Knight c7 forcing
Queen takes Knight otherwise the King
would explode after Knight takes c6 so
black simply captures it
and now White has a really nice idea to
activate the Queen now knight c6 is
played and let's see if you guys can
find the next main theoretical move for
white now if you are already atomic
theoreticians you probably know this one
but if you're new to the game it's a
really fun move to it to try and find
for yourself so try and work out White's
best move here and it's it's a difficult
one so I don't blame you if you can't
find it
don't blame you if you can't find it
all right I'm going to show it pause the
video now if you still want to look for
yourself
the move is actually Queen b6 and the
reason this is the move is because this
queen is not so easily captured if you
do take the move Bishop b5 comes on the
board and white is regaining the queen
with some extra pieces as well
King a7 is the only move that doesn't
hang checkmate due to Bishop takes pawn
and now Bishop takes pawn anyways and
these two pieces come off the board you
can imagine rook takes a two takes back
some pieces but at the end of the day
you have four pawns to four pawns well
five to five one Bishop one Bishop one
rook one rook one night and two pawns
and this brings me to my next point
about atomic chess pawns really increase
in value the reason for that is one
helpful way to think about atomic chess
and the rules is that your pieces are
always defended what does this mean well
it means that your pieces cannot be
taken ever unless the capturing piece is
willing to give itself up and in fact
it's more powerful than them being
defended because you don't even have to
spend a turn to recapture the piece the
piece just automatically is taken off
the board and what this means for puns
is that the only way to stop them is to
dedicate a full piece to just sitting in
front of the pawn they can't ever be
captured so you must dedicate a piece to
sitting in front of them otherwise they
will just continue their march up the
board and so it's easy to see why one
piece is not enough to compensate for
two pawns because if you have two pawns
rolling up the board you can't put one
piece in front of both of them and for
that reason why does simply winning here
much better than taking on b6 is
actually the move king f7 and now a
weird move from White Queen c7 is
actually the main line and the idea is
you're pinning this pawn to this King
allowing some more fun ideas with stuff
like Bishop c4
as well as Queen takes d7 being
threatened Bishop b4 is the main move
creating threats to the king
so c3 is played and now Knight h6 and
Queen f8 are the two main moves here now
the problem with Knight age 6 I'll
quickly talk about white simply takes
all of these pieces and while black does
have some immediate activity
the fact is it's just simply too many
pieces for black to handle if white
plays well you'll see this Knight stops
the rook from entering now white castles
queenside this rook does enter but it's
neatly corralled by this Bishop and from
here white is simply going to start
pushing these pawns and win the game
this of course was a game taken from the
leech chess database another high-level
atomic game between fast tsunami and a
player by the name of cress with a lot
of s's so 9 h6 the problem is Queen
takes d7 and there can be some tricky
stuff for white to handle but if white
plays well white should just use this
material edge to win a lot more testing
is actually this Queen f8 line which is
removing the Queen from the threat of
capture on d7 now what I like for white
here is actually Bishop c4 threatening
the black King and you can imagine
Bishop takes c3 it removes this threat
tactically Knight c3 now the threat is
actually Knight e4 with 95 or Knight
takes f6 to follow so f5 is blacks move
to prevent it and now actually Queen d6
comes on the board threatening checkmate
so black must capture and the idea is 95
hitting these two pieces now if you play
a move like a 6 well you're gonna hit
with 96 check and you're gonna lose even
more material so b6 is the move but now
after Knight takes a 7 we have arrived
at yet another endgame
and this is really a problem for black
all of these end games are going to be
significantly worse if not losing and in
fact this end game I believe has been
shown to be losing from the games that I
have seen a high level here in the game
we're looking at today
Bishop a6 was played trying to cut off
this King and get some activity now
though simply be for comes on the board
black tries to get active with Knight h6
f3 is the natural response to keep the
knight out of the game this Bishop comes
into f1 and this Bishop comes into a3
and white simply gives back these pieces
over on G over on g2 and h1 rook c8 is
played rook c1 actually challenges the
open file note that you do not need your
rooks to be defended to be on the open
file as they defend themselves
now black does take the material back we
see rook c7 and rook takes c7 with a
trade and b5 and we have arrived at this
interesting endgame here and you might
be thinking well material is even so how
can this be bad for black well the
reason is these pawns are going to be
coming up the board a lot more quickly
than than blacks pawns and so let's take
a look at how this game transpired I
think this is more or less the best way
for white to play white simply pushes
this pawn to a4 now after King c8 see if
you can find the winning idea for white
here
what is the winning idea for whites
what's the winning idea how can white
try to win this endgame where he's
simply even material with his opponent
Patrick Daly says a five abhinav anon
says Bishop c7 so the problem with a
five is that it actually allows black
blockade pretty nicely well I can simply
capture this pawn and now after b6 King
B seven and the problem is you can't
ever attack this B seven square and so
black is going to be easily drawing
after a at five of course the idea as
abhinav correctly said is Bishop c7 and
the idea is these two pawns together
cannot be stopped and so you're simply
going to give up this bishop for this
pawn now it's not as simple as all that
black still put up a nice defense here
and the f7 Bishop takes pawn 96 and so
the knight comes to help out to blockade
these pawns but after b6 Knight to c4
King f1 of course don't want to lose
your King Knight a5 blockades b7 King b8
blockades but now the problem for black
is there's no way to make use of his
extra pawn on the King side and he's
actually going to end up in zoogs Vung
so g5 is played and here white runs the
King up the board in front of the H pawn
these ponds are going to come off the
board and black already kind of admits
defeat with a move knight c6 when
this is over takes obviously a seven and
you cannot take due to blowing up your
own king so if black tried a bit harder
with the move
d3 well you're just going to run into f4
and already you can't really touch
either of these pawns and you're gonna
have to play knight c6 and take and now
unfortunately for black whites is
queening with check and will be easily
checkmating here and that's why white is
really to be preferred in this endgame
because the pawns being so far advanced
means that he wins in the case of all
zoogs bunks I also want to mention that
if by some happenstance here let's say
takes and okay I'm trying to set up a
position here let's say for example take
stakes was played and for some reason
white has to move this King let's say
White has to move the King like in this
position I obviously a five is possible
but even if White had to move the King
he can triangulate here with King g3 a
for King age three and even in this
position
white would in fact still be winning for
each square up the board the pawn is
white can waste another tempo with this
idea stepping to the left of the pawn
and then stepping in front of the pawn
forcing black to make a move and so even
here black or white is still winning
because in still zoogs Vung the black
King which is why this endgame is good
for white alright with that that is
where I'm going to leave you guys off on
this variance lecture hopefully you have
a pretty good understanding of atomic
chess and horde chess now as well these
are some really fun games I definitely
recommend trying them for yourself as
always my name is Caleb Ben me and I
will see you next time on the road to
2000
you
[Music]